hello my name is David Brandon you are
tuned into film courage here in la talk
radio com and I am your co-host Karen
warden today's show is Peter Alice the
host of movie buzz moviebuzz is the one
and only sexy show that will give you
the latest yes up yes you like that
up-to-date news on movies peter has
amassed over eighty thousand subscribers
to his YouTube channel and you can go to
youtube.com slash Rallis p and also he
has what 20 million video views yeah I
think it's closer to 20 21 million 20
excuse me 21 million he has done this
before graduating from college which he
will do in a couple years well let's
welcome to film courage mr. Peter
Wallace hello Peter hey hey dude doing
well it's great it's great to have you
great to have young with us Peter was
thinking once again to see Peters work
please visit youtube.com slash Rallis p
and that's our a ll is p today's hashtag
for film courage is hashtag film courage
if you would like to you know that's us
if you want to file today's conversation
on twitter you can also send your
questions for Peter to at film courage
if you want to reach us off the air
please send us an email to film Kurds at
gmail com can you tell us a little bit
about your upbringing and what attracted
you to film I merely from Bainbridge
Island Washington it's like a little
suburb of like Seattle and very grown up
my was growing up I was really the
movies and my dad was always show me the
classics like aliens and Terminator 2
when I was like eight years old so that
was a good you know for me and at the
time my mom had a was friends with the
high school basketball coach I was also
in a basketball at the time so he
brought me to one of the games to scout
and he asked me if I wanted to write
down all the stats of the game or to
film the game I thought be much easier
to fill mix I didn't want to mess up
paying the stats so I film the entire
game and then about a week later I got
an email from the basketball team saying
hey Peter thank you for filming the game
we ended up winning both those games
against those teams and I felt really
cool about that like something even
though it's just like
tell me a basketball game son recognized
what I did and thank you for it and then
ever since then I kind of wanted to
start making movies and stuff and so I
started making a lot of short films and
then when I was in high school I was
working on a short film and in the scene
there was like a football there's a
football game so I did like a football
highlight reel and I showed it to my TV
video teacher and he really liked it
because he was also one of the coaches
for the team and he told me that he
wanted to move me up into the next video
class of the TV video three four class
was more advanced and they were in
charge of the morning like to friday
morning broadcast news stuff so all of
my film stuff else I got introduced to
kind of do some kind of broadcast bored
and I had a lot of thought that that was
my sophomore year fault and then I did
the same thing junior year I was in the
same class and in my senior year the
teacher left to go work somewhere else
and everyone wanted the news to come
back so I by myself I produced every
week the Friday morning news show for my
school I I wrote it I was the anchor
forts and people know still enjoyed it
very much which was nice and also I was
one of the writers from my high school
newspaper and i wrote a Monthly article
called movie buzz because I was still
very interested in movies and the the
business and so I always write updates
the newspaper and then I got accepted to
film school in new york city of the
School of Visual Arts I was there for
about two years and that's when I
started my movie buff show on YouTube
started out very my first episodes
really terrible i like to keep it up on
my channel just to see how far I've come
since that first episode and I started
getting really involved with the YouTube
community and that's kind of what
inspired me to now transfer to Emerson
and Boston and now i'm studying
broadcast journalism stuff kind of
switch i'm still i select a chic two
short films on on my spare time but i'm
now focusing my attention on broadcast
journalism just because we're my youtube
show has taken me that's amazing i mean
you're in your early 20s right yeah I
turned 21 like three months ago okay I
mean when I was in my 20s my drive left
little to be desired will say that at
where does your drive come from and do
you think that your drive to do things
and produce content is an exception for
someone your age um yeah well I don't
want to like put down as my friends for
fatherless no but I've always been
really passionate about my work and
stuff and I like to see it my friends
recognize that to saying you know oh no
it's you've done so much and i know i
still don't know what I my major is
going to be here I don't know what I'm
doing it that and it's I'm glad to see
people recognize you know the time and
effort I put into my work mm-hmm I mean
who are your role models who do you turn
to for inspiration who do you learn from
and who do you pattern yourself after um
I really like Joel McHale who does the
soup I've kind of like that's why I kind
of update am I said to I got in spot of
green screens new lighting choice i'm
always trying to improve my show and I
like Stephen Colbert to I just think
both those guys are very quick and
snappy with their comedic timing and I
try to not necessarily copy it that I
like the idea of how quick they are with
what their reasoning and their answers
to things Peter can you just expand in
terms of what was the inspiration of you
starting movie buzz well my first video
ever uploaded to YouTube was back in my
senior year I did a decades dance video
I had this kind of promotion thing for a
dance at the school he films like
various dances throughout the decades I
upload to youtube and it got like five
got quite a big hit count and so I was
kind of that's what I first got involved
in YouTube community I was watching some
other content creators and then this one
guy michael buckley he does what the
buck show he got featured on youtube I
know sitting like a news type of thing
we're here like what he's I quite like
the godfather of like the reporters for
you to browse like I think I can do that
because what he was doing was kind of
mixed between my broadcast stuff I was
doing in high school and my movie buzz
articles and so I'm like well I could
combine the two like I can do that I can
take my broadcasting my movie buzz I'll
make it a show
notice that not no one was really
talking about movie news on youtube so
Mike I need to jump on this before
anyone else does so I was lucky with my
timing with getting involved in YouTube
community just because how big it is now
how hard it is to make your own show now
than it was two years ago I mean two
years ago the number one subscriber had
like a hundred thousand subscribers now
the number one subscriber has two
million subscribers and so I was lucky
to join the website at a time that there
wasn't too many people that was able to
kind of start my show up and it was
really fun because I really enjoy you
know looking for the various news stuff
and be able to report on it Peter can
you talk a little bit about your the
first episode that just shot you know
did you have any equipment at that time
did you have to borrow it I mean how did
you get that first the first one off the
ground how did you edit it well for my
garage as a graduation president my mom
gave me Final Cut Pro which was a really
great big help because that's a
fantastic editing software and my first
episode I just shot it with my the
webcam has built into my computer and I
just kind of talked I was like in my
dorm room that lad 0 lighting but I put
a suit on so made it look like a little
professional and I was just I was very
slow with my delivery and it really
wasn't the greatest and then I brought
they had then I bought a video camera I
was shooting my stuff on that but I was
just shooting on a bare walls still not
very good lighting at all and then when
I came home for winter break i was able
to shoot in the same kind of studio that
i was using when I was swimming my
morning broadcast in high school so
looked a little better but then I got
back to school I did still have anything
set up and then this my second year of
doing it I bought a red piece of foam
core board from staples which I used for
like a year and a half and then it
wasn't until this semester actually
bought a green screen some lighting I
got a new microphone I've got a new
camera so I'm always looking to kind of
improve the quality of my shell was
trying to make it better than the last
episode and how many people watched the
first episode um my first my first
episode came out i had about like 40
subscribers cuz i was posting some other
like stuff
like other various blog type of stuff my
first episode had like 40 subscribers I
can like it got it like about a thousand
hits and then I will for like out about
a month and a half I got a thousand hits
and then by the time it took me until I
spy first episode was december six two
thousand seven and then may of 2008 so
about nine months or less nest seven or
eight months i got a thousand
subscribers and then I was able to join
the partner program and start making a
little bit of some money from my videos
which is which has been nice for
part-time job wise yeah I bet we're
gonna be getting into that anymore a
little bit but well how did you promote
it you know what tools did you use and
who did you promote it to well why first
starting off I mean probably one of the
best things to do especially for people
on YouTube is to go to all the YouTube
gatherings really like YouTube is very
much centered around its kind of who you
know that gets you win it's like what
you know that it keeps you there and it
was great because with the gatherings i
would meet various youtubers and even
want to collab with me or get me shout
out so i give them shout outs and the
big youtube gathering that's coming up
this summer is in Los Angeles called
VidCon thing all the informations on
VidCon 2010.com and this is a big
YouTube community like all the big
youtubers will be there so I think I
feel that she I'll be there as well and
so it's great trans people to meet each
other and kind of collaborate that's
kind of how I got my start me on my
second episode of movie buzz Michael
Buckley from what the buck show
commented on it it was kind of a big
have inspiration to see what these
people who've done a lot kind of
inspired me to do well and he was always
a big supporter my stuff but I think the
number one thing is you have to there's
a lot of interacting and getting
connections and that's kind of what
helped me out big time is like this is
very much in the business world it's the
same on making videos on the internet
can you talk about the f the early
effort that you put in to kind of grow
moviebuzz to grow your channel I mean
you went from 40 subscribers to a
thousand what what kind of effort did
that take well luckily my content is
movie-related
and so when people will search for
trailers my videos would come up you
know that's jelly my video would be what
they're looking for it would also along
with because I always linked to the
information I'm talking about so when a
new trailer does come out I can link to
that or other news stories so so people
originally found me it was because they
were looking for something else but
ended up liking what they what they saw
which was he not nice i noticed in my
statistics for my videos sixty percent
my views comes from related videos so
someone's Washington trailer for an LLC
iron man two in the related video
section my videos would come up as well
because I also talked about iron iron
man two and that's how I my audience was
able to find me so I'm lucky enough to
have a show about content that people
search for quite often search for
trailers are moving you so that's been
helpful as well I'm curious what was the
first video that really caught on and
that kind of gave you the push to keep
going and saying you know what I'm onto
something I talked about the first when
the trailer for The Incredible Hulk came
out the second one that got about an
actually my first video was I'll talk
about the Cloverfield monster because
don't do what the Cloverfield monster
looked like and so I had a photo think
like a this what the monster looks like
and that's where everyone was like
really caught on to that because he
thought oh you know this is the photo I
got some information some inside scoop
and ever I got I've got quite a bit of
subscribers off that I remember the
number if I remember like wow like this
kids really catching out like people
looking for his information I'm like I'm
the guy to go do so that was a real big
help for my show with the way that you
talk about movies being honest and
candid I'm sure it attracts its share of
detractors should we say and obsess it
hasn't taken long for people to maybe
start bashing you and what you're doing
what are your thoughts on haters and how
do you handle them no haters come in all
shapes and sizes but uh but uh I like
them because well for well what is
constructed by like them because when i
started out at terrible Lighting's would
say hey you're lighting sucks like okay
well the night it gets me to fix that
lighting or someone say you're talking
too fast or contents or the shows too
long or this contents boring like will
KO n'ya step it up so
I like the nice comments always good
shows i'm doing a good job but i like
reading the people will say that i
sucked because they okay well then did
you do better next time so it almost
helps shape you then the absolutely did
they ever get you down Peter I mean do
they ever like you know start to wear on
you I mean how do you how do you
insulate yourself from from from the
constant just bagging or you know just
people coming down on you almost like
when people really come down on me is
like when I review movies like when
people disagree with me they really
really disagree with me like I got a
whole lot of backlash when I said that
avatar was in my favorite film people
were just like you don't know anything
but then again it's like I'm not
something I'm wrong it's just that this
is what my thoughts of it work yeah you
always think that they're only when it
comes reviewing it's like they're always
right and waiting with things
differently is wrong I have a Pacific
opinion about it some people like it
some people agree with it but when
people don't they really really disagree
with me but I think it's fun because I
like putting a conversation like having
my my viewers you know it's like I'm
trying to create a conversation as
opposed to this is everything I believe
in this is everything is just really
like people responding to what I have to
say and kind of because like people talk
about movies because i think you know
movies are great and when people are
talking about it it's always a good time
you are listening the film curves we
broadcast live every sunday 12 p.m.
pacific standard time here in la talk
radio com we're interviewing peter
rallis to see his work please visit
youtube.com slash Rallis p and once
again that's our ALL is p if you have
questions for Peter Bravo's please send
them to twitter at film courage you can
also use the hashtag hashtag film
courage as we mentioned earlier in the
show I mean you've built up a subscriber
base of over 80,000 people and your
videos have over you know 20 plus
million views how much money have you
invested in your show and can you
estimate how much it has cost you to
build up your brand
well having to go see all the movies i
guess that kind of plays into my cost of
the show okay but when I was first
starting out it didn't cost me a single
dime to produce my jokes I was feeling
well I had to buy my camera but I also
needed that for school suddenness really
see it as a cost was just like oh good
thing I have a camera to shoot this but
recently when i upgraded my studio about
a month ago when I bought the green
screen about a couple lights and a
microphone that total cost was 150 bucks
which was pretty nice and my old camera
broke I think God it was cylinder a
warranty so I got a free replacement
even better camera I and my total
upgrade costs for my priests Michelle
was about 150 bucks with the lights and
buying the green screen which I got very
cheap I was very lucky about hitting
that and I don't know if we've gone into
specifics I'm looking at the screen here
we got a question from Jake stetler and
he's asking what's camera and editing
software do you use for your show on the
camera God's is a sony vixia camera let
me get the real specifics real quick you
know I've actually used the Sony vixia
hv30 for our film goodbye promise so I
gotta vixia hf s 10 or the 8's 104 false
cameras but yeah it's a it's a HD camera
i got it for it's about 1,100 bucks and
it's a hard drive camera too so I'm able
to film a lot of content on that and
then I edit with final cut pro on my
macbook pro God so and that I've been
using that system for two years has been
working out absolutely great for me and
can you talk about the tipping point for
movie buzz I mean the point where all
the work that you were putting in
finally got to got to the point where
where your audience started doing the
work for you you know that the point
where where moviebuzz kind of took on a
life of its own yeah it's really
important to when i started my shelter i
was very consistent like at the end of
the tail on the end of a new shows
tuesdays and fridays so at the end of a
Tuesday show say okay that's all for
today's show and I'll see you on Friday
so people know when to expect a new
video and on fridays i'll say I'll see
you on Tuesday cut
be consistent with that and telling
people when to expect a new video kind
of helps to keep your audience coming
back as opposed to well that was a nice
video I don't know when I'll see that
guy again so let them know that i'll be
back in a couple days kind of makes
people kind of stay and usually my
subscriber base jumps a lot when it
comes to the summer movies that are
coming out like when i go when the iron
man two trailer got released i got a big
boost in views because he always wants
what the trailer was I had other news to
help you know rapport along with that
and so kind of helps depends depends on
what movie i'm talking about it kind of
so people are really looking for iron
man two are really looking for the Hulk
then I'm luckily enough that my videos
were there well when they search for
that once you reach the thousand
subscribers or 10,000 subscribers like
when did you see it just really kind of
become its own animal um well it didn't
really get a big a huge amount jump I
noticed it was kind of fun exponentially
kind of growing it coming okay I got
this night today there's a little more
the next day and there were there wasn't
necessarily a big point where it really
took off like sharp took off but I could
tell that because like once you get more
subscribers it's easier to get that next
2,000 then it was when he first started
like when my first trip to a thousand
took me longer than it was giving me to
2000 and just because I had more people
commenting and you know rating my videos
and discussing it was kind of kind of
like a natural growth to it there was no
kind of like big spike after one video
than another okay I you know I don't
know we have this side question coming
in from 20 boy or Tony boy and like I
said this is kind of just a little
wrench here but what's Peters opinion on
the european film industry well i I've
seen European films I don't really know
how the business works but a great film
that came out of the UK was pirate radio
or for them it was the boat the boat
that rocked I thought that was a great
film I don't see a whole lot of foreign
movies just because I have to keep
current with you know the movies are
coming on Hollywood in America just
taking my show but I'd only know that
much about the European market oh come
on coming back to this in terms of
building an audience what are some of
the nuts and bolts of building an
audience on you two
you know what what should be in the
title what should we have an information
section what what do we use as tags you
know your your thoughts on video
responses your thoughts on allowing
negative comments and and you've already
kind of touched on that we should be
posting frequently and letting people
know when we're posting content but can
you kind of go into some of the nuts and
bolts yeah it's always great to network
I mean if you have if you start because
first of all if you are like a filmmaker
and you have a lot of short films i
recommend putting those on youtube like
it's like today like as fast as you can
because the site is growing unbelievably
fast and according to new york times 20
hours of video is uploaded every minute
to this site every minute 20 hours which
is the equivalent to a hundred thousand
full-length movies every week so you're
also competing against not necessarily
other people's content but just didn't
like the amount of videos that are on
the site when that iphone 3gs came out
the tip took videos they could also
upload to youtube from your phone
there's a four hundred percent increase
of uploaded videos so there's a huge
like that it's very competitive right
now and the best way do you have to go
to those gatherings VidCon will be great
this summer um you gotta interrupt
people on Twitter you just have to be
very immersed in kind of the community
you need to respond to comments even the
hate ones just like you just kind of
keep the conversation going need to be
consistent when it comes to uploading
videos and your make sure you always
always looking to improve your content
I'm looking I always never satisfied
with my last one we trying to make my
newest video better than my last video
but yeah it's very important to know
networking is huge when it comes the
internet because someone's always there
to help you out or you're always there
to help someone else out I've made a lot
of amazing people to my show and I'm
very blessed to kind of be the spot
where i am now than where i could have
been if i was just kind of okay with my
work it wasn't too happy about it or
kind of kick as if if I was still doing
my show today how look the first episode
I would be stuck with I don't even know
I've you just very terrible and then can
you also touch on the specifics in terms
of you know what what how creative
should we be with our titles because I
noticed you do some great stuff on your
YouTube page
and once again we're talking youtube.com
slash Rallis p you know even the even
the design background ground getting
people to subscribe links to Twitter and
Facebook can you touch on some of that
technical stuff uh yes for title wise
what I was doing for about 200 episodes
I always say like movie buzz and then I
would name my episode didn't have the
title and I realized that that wasn't
really helping my stuff I'd rather have
my title and that put the movie buzz par
at the end because when people are
searching for the videos they're looking
for the content first as opposed to what
the name of your show is first so like I
would say moviebuzz to 15 iron man two
trailer will that become a push down
towards the end of the title so now I'm
just saying iron man two trailer first
that what people can look for the
content they're searching for first
before it comes to because no one if you
don't know what my show is they're not
looking for the title in my show and
that kind of had bumps back what they're
doing um so always put whatever the main
content of the video is that needs to be
the first words of your title and then
at the end you could say and this is
movie buzz you know at the end of what
of your title is that helps lot and for
descriptions sometimes people will add
tags that haven't really nothing to do
with your video I could be a video about
their cats and then at the end we'll put
a hashtag like boobs in it just in case
that way their video will come up which
is really a cheap way to do it but uh
it's really good just keep your tags
kind of sing with the title or you put
tags in it has some to do with the
content of as well so when I talk about
like behind the scenes of clash the
Titans I'll put in are sometimes behind
the scenes in my tags and that helps a
lot like to it's like as many relevant
tags you can put in your videos the
bigger it will help with your viewership
let's take a what if scenario here i'm
gonna throw out kind of a debbie downer
question here ok let's say the internet
was reset and everyone lost all of their
account information and networks and you
lost everything and had to build up what
you've worked so hard for for the past
few years if you had to start over today
what would be your plan of attack how
would you begin to build up your
audience knowing what you now know
like about a started you like a brand
new YouTube channel just everything yeah
um i would say consistent with what i
was doing because that's kind of what
got me where i was in the first place
was because i gotta be consistent like
if someone want to start a show today it
finds something that you love to do
because i luckily i found this thing
that i love talking about moving news i
love reporting on it and it's easier for
people to make more and more videos
about something if it's something that
they like reporting on like some people
talk about my friend will he does the
winners and losers he talks about like
people who are moving up and down
subscribers and talk about other news
that's happening in the community like
that's what is that's what his thing is
and some people talkin michael buckley
does his pop culture stuff that's
something he loves to do so if you see
if you can find something that you're
very passionate about it's very easy to
be consistent with it and I think if I
perhaps start over again I would still
be doing anything I'm doing now I would
be make sure to let people know when to
expect my videos the next ones coming
out how to follow me on Twitter you know
how to know Facebook fan me or whatever
because it's networking on the internet
is very important because everyone's
connected to someone somehow and it's
it's like the internet is huge and its
capabilities socially great to kind of
have people around that can help you out
and helping them to and Peter one thing
that's happened with you and in terms of
syndication is that is that you you're
now involved with Indy mogul who's
picked up your channel so did you
contact indymogul about tapping into
their audience or did they approach you
they approached me back in October of
2009 they was part of the company called
next new networks and they are they're
in charge of a bunch of different
YouTube channels they do barely
political barely digital indymogul and
some other various people and they came
to me and they want me to join indymogul
family and then back in december we
flank and all that worked out and what's
really helping me now is that since I've
put myself out on the internet and it's
really great because even if you're even
do any kind of media like you just not
just news if you have music videos or if
you're an artist or your musician like
put yourself out there on the internet
you may even get some bad clash
you gotta do it because someone will
find you someone will absolutely find
you and some new musicians have signed
out with some labels who started off on
YouTube I know uh Andrew Garcia was on
American Idol he was on YouTube and now
p what is a big supporting from the
community but yeah indymogul I signed
with any mogul and they're not helping
should be my videos to the other sites
like msn video in their own websites and
they're looking to help me out and send
me to hopefully South by Southwest next
year but it's really great and if you're
just consistent always improving some
will notice and some will help you out
and even get an interview on film
courage so it's all nice thank you good
segue we actually have a question coming
in from marinelle Montella's and and
she's asking are you aware about the
recent videos about raywilliamjohnson
put out by philip defranco of the philip
defranco of the philip de France I'm
sorry Philip de France show channel on
YouTube about ray william johnson
cheating the system to get more
subscribers wow what are what would for
the qualities what for you are the
qualities of a successful YouTube
channel besides having millions of
subscribers um well raise a personal
friend of mine so I don't wanna ok same
two thing but I'm okay but there's well
the problem is with with like like
situations like that is that there's
currently a big lawsuit going on between
Viacom and YouTube about copyright laws
and and outside of YouTube the fair use
laws will make it able to people to you
know use trailers or other footage as
part of the show but somehow for being
on YouTube it's like some other kind of
dramas because the internet is like this
whole medium is so new then um people
know how to work with it yet that's why
there was a whole writer strike because
of everyone not getting the right amount
of money off of the stuff that was
happening on the internet but some users
have other content that that may be
protected or not protected but you gotta
be careful because some to even even
some audio issues on search on youtube
they can just remove your video
a copper if it gets in the way of any
copyright laws but i I've tried I've
tried to steer away from that just to
make sure that my videos are still up on
and available so it is much easier first
you can become a partner too if you have
like a hundred percent original content
but with people who have done otherwise
me everyone is deserving of their
subscribers some people want their
subscribers for different reasons some
people just want to be the number one on
YouTube other people are using as
launching pads for their careers like
some musicians and other craters have
done so it's a great way just to be seen
and if you're I mean especially for a
filmmaker like put your videos on the
internet copyright the way you can but
absolutely put your stuff out there it's
very easy to put yourself out there I
know one filmmaker made a short film
like a great grade short film he got
picked up by some big companies in from
that from like universal or DreamWorks
or something but he just signed a deal
because they found this guy's short film
that was so great and now he has a lot
of opportunities that come up what kind
of opportunities have opened up for you
because of the audience that you've
built for movie buzz I mean have you
received any TV show offers and are
there any folks from Hollywood who have
approached you um I've had I've met some
people uh a fear of the film tropic
thunder the kid he was only the film for
like two seconds but he was people I met
through McConaughey son he was like in
the phone i was on the jet i play at the
end i met he watches my show and so I've
kind of quite that low connection but as
for like stuff that's coming my way I've
had indymogul talk to me and recently
MTV approached me to audition for a new
pop culture show so i send my audition
tape for that so hopefully that if that
if i get that that'd be really fantastic
yeah so that's the only all kind of
offer stuff but try keep myself
connected and made that other people are
looking to help promote their work as
well I'm glad to help out any of them
anyone else that kind of needs extra
push for viewership because if your
content is good it's very easy for
people that you need to help promote you
just got to be consistent with your work
and what efforts are you are you doing
to maintain nurture and grow your
audience I mean how do you continue to
connect with them well I like to respond
she's many mess
is that I can't the people who like ask
me questions like they're like outside
the movie buzz or you want to know what
kind of some extra information I can
send it to them I just created that
Facebook fan page that way it's even
easier for me to talk to people in
between shows and making sure that you
know okay this is coming up or I even on
Twitter I'll post movie news in between
shows that maybe we'll make it into the
show or like breaking news that I want
people know about it right away it's the
way people outside of youtube so i
create an audience on twitter or create
an audience on facebook that are they're
always looking for me for that that
movie news like I want to be like the
guy that they go to for that like I want
to be like oh 10 what Peter all else has
to say about this and I'm I'm trying to
build up outside of YouTube as many
people as I can to kind of keep my show
consistent and bringing even new viewers
as well you touched on this earlier you
know you did mention that there is money
coming in from youtube I want to ask is
is moviebuzz is it paying for your
college um it's not paying for my
college but it's definitely paying for
my rent which is good and so am ii so
you have been able to monetize your
efforts through youtube absolutely
absolutely and that's through the
partner program can you talk a little
bit about that how a partner program
works is that once you have a specific
number of subscribers and consistent
your base I could give a thousand
subscribers but you only have five
people viewing your views doing your
video so it really doesn't no help for
YouTube butt's going to make sure you're
consistently uploading videos so you
have a strong subscriber base that's
also view in your content don't scream a
partner you start getting ad revenue and
still the ads that appear to the right
of my video that's where I get my
contents when p.s forget my revenues and
people check out the advertisers that's
how that comes in so the more
subscribers I get and the more people
view my videos the revenue is higher
than it was if someone were to you know
watch the video as much and then how
hard is it to get into the partner
program well now it's harder just
because how many people are on the site
but once like their base for joining the
partner program is a thousand
subscribers so once you hit a thousand
and you see that you have my original
copyright free content and you have a
consistent you're uploading videos
consistently because if you only upload
a video once every month or once a week
you know three months they're not going
to allow you in but many a lot of people
are every day are becoming partners
YouTube it's really helped them out and
even changed some people's lives with
the end up going their job and just
making their living off of youtube and
and you know because we're talking about
subscribers here what would you say that
the best way to get to a thousand
subscribers you know obviously you
talked about you know getting content on
a consistent basis but you know what
ways can we actually attract the
subscribers to get them to come to jump
aboard yeah yeah well just because it's
mostly networking if you see your future
you just started shell let's say about
music news of some were to reach out to
me and say hey Peter now I just start
this new show can you help me out with
you know viewership or doing do a
collaboration usually collaborations are
the biggest thing to help out our new
users is if they are involved with
another big youtuber my first since
Shane Dawson Dino has like no million
subscribers and if someone's contents
good enough that he wants to do a little
bit collaboration with them it could
bring a whole new viewership to those
people and subscribers can jump up a big
time because it and they're also a new
also a great new thing that YouTube
started about on a hollow most but
having like a maybe a year ago we'll be
out of people in your box and some
people tonight I put my friends in my
box who need extra subscribers and what
that is on my channel page I have about
14 like channels that I recommend and
when people subscribe to me they also
have the option of instantly subscribing
to them as well and you see that they're
in my like recommended boxed and they're
more likely to subscribe to those people
too so some of my friends who just
started I have a friend Ben who does
music and I put him in my subscriber
like my recommended box that's really
helped him out to sew along with your
networking not necessarily fool if like
you can't do a collaboration you may be
chance maybe get in someone's box and
that could help out your viewership as
well just because the person will see
well this person who has a ton of
subscribers likes this other channels so
I might like it as well
are you monetizing your efforts in other
ways outside of YouTube well I get some
help with my stuff I do with any mobile
but it's basically I've just been
getting that just for my YouTube stuff
and ending mobile survive no others
projects i'm working on yet and and and
and what's next for you i mean you still
don't graduate from college until may of
2011 I mean I know how do you grow from
here um you know are things still
growing for you do you feel snagged
stagnant yeah I'm really happy with
where my show is now and I feel like I'm
a place where like a lot of good things
are going to start be happy I feel like
2010's can be good year I'm looks I
looking for the VidCon and be great way
to network with even more big people who
are all part of the community and to
just do not necessarily youtube videos
but like any other content website
people will be there as well so yeah I'm
excited about because i'm glad i have at
least a year and a half left until i
graduate work I could still because my
shows been going more and more every
year I feel like by the time I graduate
I'll be at a point where opportunities
outside you two will be very uh then
we'll be there for me once I graduate do
you encourage your friends to build
their own brands around their passions
um yeah absolutely i know some while my
friends who have seen what kind of ripe
and where i am now on youtube they
always typo aww like I want to have a
show on YouTube you know I got it but I
don't know what to do but a lot of my
friends were free hilarious I just gonna
be if they just a regular blogs and
vlogs that they'll be able to get it out
there content uh fairly easily but yeah
the internet is hugely it me it's
growing at such a rate it's almost
becoming an almost might kill television
at one point meet Eve you always be
there but the amount of people who go
and watch videos online is a lot more
than people who watch a lot of TV shows
that are learning some videos getting
millions of views that some TV shows
will never get and it's law stuff is
moving more technology me everything's
becoming less less and less papers but
fan
yo just introduced a new application
where when you buy movie tickets you can
have like a little bar code on your cell
phone and be able to scan that as
opposed to like printing out tickets
from your printer like everything's
becoming paperless you know I think
newspapers in art could be around that
much longer I mean the online like
newyorktimes.com will be huge but i
don't think the paper circulation will
be around there's just a lot of like you
can literally find everything on the
internet and if you want to create a
name for yourself and brand for yourself
or just just advertising for even if the
even for you even if you're like the
head of some kind of like real estate
company just to be prevalent on the
internet and to advertise yourself it's
a fantastic way to do that because you
knit like you literally never know who
will find you and did put yourself out
there like some will find it and good
things or great things can happen from
it you know I'd like to take a moment I
haven't had a chance to do this yet I
want to thank all of the people that are
tuned in right now lorraine SF the lone
olive circles of fire Jake stetler david
p baker la actress paid patty fantasia
urge indesign synthetic fur gets stuck
marry now tous kyun mr. window films
just just the name of you and Peter you
mentioned this vid con and you said it's
going to be in Los Angeles yes it's
taking place at a hotel but all the
information is at VidCon 2010.com okay
um it's a three-day event oh it's like a
friday saturday sunday type of thing you
know we're definitely gonna look into
the hopefully we can see out there with
it you said that's in May or when is
that exactly it's in July it's July 9th
to the 11 um and I guess this lastly
we're just gonna ask you where do you
see yourself in five years all I would
like to have kind of take moviebuzz to
the next level I feel like that's
something I know it's very high high
thinking but I would I really like what
I'm doing either if I become may be a
full-time critic is maybe can stay away
from the news part but i really enjoy
the stuff I'm doing in the people that
I'm meeting and all that but I would
really like to
kind take moviebuzz as far as you can go
because I have a absolutely fantastic
time doing it I'm always looking to
improve and make my show better too well
we have been speaking with Peter Alice
of moviebuzz for more about Peters work
please visit youtube.com slash Rallis p
well thank you again Peter thank you
very much better thank you for all these
in sizes great yeah I'm great really
some great nuts and bolts around in
YouTube in building an audience some but
they looking forward to talking to you
for a while yeah thank thank you for
joining us today well thank you very
much as a lot of fun thank you Peter
telling the universe what we want is
essential for manifesting goals yet as
much as we say we aspire to something
some of us are guilty of sending the
universe mixed signals I'm thinking of
myself as I read this like an ex lover
who calls us to reunite only to
disappear a few weeks later we fluctuate
between putting our effort into a
project and then retracting affirmations
are a great way to solidify baby steps
toward our goals posting signs around
the house or repeating an inner mantra
starts the process moving forward one of
the most notable writers on affirming
and manifesting goals is louise hay
louise hay was born in 1926 in her early
years she endured sexual and physical
abuse as well as a life of poverty she
dropped out of high school and gave up a
child for adoption around the time she
was 15 determined to live a better life
Louise left home at a young age things
fared better for Louise some years after
she held a career as a fashion model and
married a prominent businessman this
seemingly better life took her into a
new class and interesting set of
experiences Louise's life took many more
twists and turns she would later divorce
become a minister in a church dedicated
to the new thought movement and come
down with cervical cancer Louise felt
that her cervical cancer was caused by a
resentment toward her prior abuse
determined to cure herself of the cancer
through non-traditional methods Louise
changed her diet
practice reflexology and stopped her
negative thinking within six months hey
claims her cancer was gone even before
her cancer Louise had written a pamphlet
about healing one's body and the mental
connection to health troubles she
believed all ailments were caused by
specific thoughts in the 1980's Louise
began support groups for people
suffering from HIV and AIDS her work
with and acceptance of AIDS patients
when most of the medical community was
baffled by the disease led her to
television and speaking engagements
including Oprah and Phil Donahue the
little pamphlet on healing the body
eventually became a book in 1984
entitled you can heal your life you can
heal your life remained on the New York
Times bestseller list for 13 consecutive
weeks she later began Hay House
Publishing continued to write numerous
books and developed you can heal your
life into a film paraphrasing louise's
reminder that affirmations in whatever
form do work she says most people do
affirmations for a few days and then
stop claiming that they don't work when
the first Little Chute comes up that
closely resembles what we want we stomp
on it because it isn't a million dollars
we have to give things a chance to grow
this has been another episode of film
courage on la talk radio please join us
again next week for more interviews to
inspire and educate have a great week